hi everyone my name is Aleta battle
angel and this is a leta battle angel
Jessa I tried to make my eyes bigger
with white makeup and it just they
didn't really red and itchy hi everyone
my name is tiara chambers Tamara just uh
I just went and saw Aleta battle angel I
am gonna be super honest I was not
looking forward to seeing this and it
had so much hype even though I knew
really nothing about it I went into it
thinking ah it just kind of looks like a
CGI not mess the CGI looked good but I
don't know
it didn't capture my attention at all
with the trailers and so I went into
this two hour and 20 minute film
thinking like oh my just don't want to I
don't want to I don't want to and I left
pleasantly surprised I know nothing
about the manga that this is based off
of I never know if it's gonna affect the
way that I feel about it so I did Death
Note
Tamara's never seen and I watched the
first ten episodes of Death Note and
then I watched the Netflix movie I know
that the Netflix Death Note is like
notoriously known as being terrible but
I think having a little bit of context
really made me hate it like join in with
the pitchforks and fire with this I
don't know if it was true to the story I
don't know if it looked like the manga I
don't I don't know in that context at
all how it lines up I will say it's long
I will say that there are some moments
that feel draggy and that just comes
with a two hour and 20 minute movie I
think but overall I thought that the
relationships were really good maybe a
little cheesy but fun in a way that got
me invested the character development
was pretty good for not knowing these
characters beforehand jumping in I
definitely felt for them and cared about
them which is more than I can say about
some films action was out of this world
it was so good there's this ball game
motormouth
or they're on rollerskates and they're
trying to catch this ball and run a
whirly ball well I don't remember what
school but it's show thrilling to watch
those games I hate watching sports in
movies I couldn't even get behind
Quidditch Quidditch Quidditch the Harry
Potter sport it does nothing for me but
this I looked forward to every single
game when they showed up on the arena I
was pumped I think my favorite thing out
of the movie though was the world
building it gave me a very big like dark
city vibe with like how detailed the
world was I just watched that recently
for Tamra's never seen and that was like
my favorite part of the film this is
like a lot brighter than that and I know
that this world was already kind of
created in the manga so like world
building wasn't like completely on the
the film it was already a made-up thing
but they did a really good job I think
even though I don't know what the source
material is on making it it just felt so
detailed and cool I think it excited me
because I am NOT an anime fan I'm not
not a fan but I just I have not found
that anime yet that has like drawn me in
to want to start watching anime I've
seen just a few episodes of a few things
and I just I know that one day I will
get into it and this is not that day so
I always go to these movies feeling a
little not left out as in the word
because I could easily let myself in but
a little out of the loop
it was pretty anime they weren't holding
back for audiences who didn't know what
was going on but I still easily was able
to keep up with like the tone of it and
keep up with the style of it it didn't
feel I don't know when I saw what just
came out what was that one you know the
one I felt like I don't know that I like
this and maybe that's because I'm
into anime and like maybe I'm missing
something here here I didn't feel like I
was missing anything I do not think that
you need to be an anime fan to see this
movie if you like me and didn't know
what Alena battle angel was all about it
is about this cyborg
surgeon I know so much it's about the
cyber doctor who takes Aleta from the
junkyard he rebuilds her and she has no
memory of who she is
they quickly learned that she is an
intense fighting machine and then it's
really about her falling in love finding
a family and more importantly defeating
the evil that is I know but I don't know
if this is a spoiler so I won't say it
but Nova was played by someone that I
was definitely not expecting Nova to be
you don't see much of Nova which I will
say he's not that big of a threat I know
I think that's coming in the future
movies but there's a greater threat
skier on there earth-dwelling planet
versus the one up in the sky again I
know so much about this story but back
to that the cast is killer Rosa Salazar
who I don't know that I know her from
anything else she was so good as Aleta
it's so intriguing to me to do a part
like that where it looks like you but
it's most it's all CGI it's kind of like
video game acting which I definitely
want to do at some point where you're
kind of you're in that green suit is
that how they did this and you're just
like going through the motions but it's
all CGI on top of you Christoph Waltz
plays dr. IDO I love him I think he's
great in everything that he does and he
was really good in this I also just
loved the character he started off as
the father who's like you couldn't do
anything you're a fighter well you can't
fight and instead of keeping that harsh
tone the whole time which a lot of
characters like that do he was able to
really change his point of view and
allow her to be who she is and I think
that was a really really well-done
character I don't know where I was going
he wasn't really it was really well done
and sure that's probably from the manga
but it was really well done here
Jennifer Connelly's my girl that I loved
her and she was great
and chezj samokhin mashallah Ali was
great as well everything that he's in is
just a masterpiece I didn't I didn't
know who the cast was going to this I
just had no interest in this movie and
so people kept popping up and I kept
being like wow okay
you dumb Tamara a lot of the characters
you can't you don't even know who they
are because they're complete machines
complete CGI machines and those
characters look amazing they're so well
designed and this really makes me want
to read the manga I really want to see
what was taken from that what was
shifted and changed how well they
adapted it if they made things better
something that I really liked in the
relationship between Aleta and the guy
that she likes Hugo he is that he was a
really positive and upbeat and kind of
young character he goes through some
things where he's falling in love with
Aleta and he's also stealing parts from
other machines and cyborgs it's kind of
a gray area for them because she is a
cyborg any of that he's so he's kind of
an innocent guy I think we're so used to
right now seeing lead male characters
and female characters just but like the
lead young cute heartthrob character as
being like this funny confident
quick-witted and he was a little goofy
and I don't know if I liked that
alarm I also love that we have such a
badass character in Aleta I think she's
so cool
so well done she looks great the actions
amazing her fighting is so thrilling to
watch and then also she's not super sexy
and I love that I didn't realize it
until like 3/4 of the way through and
she's fighting and I'm like just so
excited and into it and I love a good
sexy fighter definitely but it was
really
cool to see someone just really good at
what they're doing and also not
hyper-sexualized she literally slices
one of her tears with a sword and that
is a self-care tactic that I've never
even dreams I love it I know my enemy is
he's watching us now and you're just
asleep and I just a good girl I thought
this movie ruled I'm getting pumped
talking about it again let's see it it's
so different than what I thought I was
gonna be maybe I went in with really low
expectations and then was just kind of
jumbled into this excitement train but I
loved it I don't think you need to know
the source material going in and that's
the best I love that it's fun to be in
on the secret of seeing a movie like
this but when you're able to see it
without having been in on the secret
without having read the manga or the
comic or whatever the case may be the
book before and to still be able to
really enjoy it I think that's a huge
accomplishment for these filmmakers and
these actors and storytellers and I
think it's awesome thank you so much for
watching I will see you all next week
probably with How to Train Your Dragon 3
I have to watch all of them before
before I see that
[Music]